[Musique]
j'ai remonté
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on a la réception de l'acier
des matières premières pour faire la
sculpture de la commande publique de
valenciennes qui sera livrée si tout va
bien un juin où un train de juin 2013
[Musique]
le projet est né depuis longtemps là ça
va être la menace et la finalité en
parce que c'est la réalisation finale
c'est le procès de la construction de
l'oeuvre
l'heure est déjà vendue elle est déjà
été étudiées ça fait plus un projet sur
lequel je travaille depuis déjà plus
d'un an et demi
donc c'est toujours très long devrait
aboutir les commandes publiques
l'assainissement décuplée alarie la
rencontre il ya l'analyse du site
ensuite la réflexion d'un atelier de
conte d'une pièce pour le site
la citation d'une oeuvre par le conseil
municipal et les insultes larry nations
qui commence aujourd'hui
valenciennes a la particularité d'être
une ville dont la mémoire industrielle
été très forte au niveau des aciers et
lorsque j'ai eu la rénovation de la
métare des mères très connu ils ont
décidé de mener des politiques
culturelles très forte pour justement
redynamiser la vie et y attirer de
nouveaux habitants et l'art contemporain
a été un des vecteurs de ce renouveau
donc ils ont choisi une ligne artistique
qui est la sculpture monumentale et la
sculpture géométriques donc valenciennes
à cette politique d'acquisition
d'oeuvres ou alors de prêts d'oeuvres
c'est dans ce cadre-là par bon travail
que j'ai été démarché par le
maire-adjoint pour pour présenter un
projet
voilà c'est cesser le travail qui
arrivait lancé
la commande de valenciennes et du
commando formidable parce que j'ai été
invité par la ville à venir
la choisir où le maire adjoint à la
culture
l'invention dimanche après midi on a
fait le tour de la ville un homme
expliquant toutes les communes d'airé
passé donc ça va de marque 0-1 normal
d'iwork tous les grands sculpteurs et
ensuite
donc on m'a demandé de choisir un lieu
et c'est moi qui après une journée après
avoir déambulé et choisir l'espace qui
convenait ce que je souhaitais faire et
j'en ai fait la proposition et c'est
exactement là qu'ils voulaient que je
sois donc donc finalement il n'y a aucun
moment il ya quelque chose qui est
imposé il a vraiment le souci de ce que
donnait un artiste la possibilité de
faire ce qu'il veut et là où il veut et
ça c'est très important et c'est celle
de sony bien parce que c'est assez rare
ce genre ce genre de choses
[Musique]
j'avais aucun plan j'ai tenu compte de
l'avis même du mieux qu'ils lui rendent
place qui fait à la fois office de rond
point que le public traverse et qui est
sur le tour de ville dans les visions
sont apparents dans ascendante ou
descendante du coup j'ai tenu circulaire
dgt du coach et ses paramètres physiques
de l'espace pour une pièce et quand on
travaille très compliqué dans la
monumentalité parce qu'une ligne sont
complexes et pour le pr neta c'est donc
là par exemple sur une coupe la
sculpture pas sortir et ateliers d'art
de toujours donc c'est très compliqué
donc du coup je me suis dit c'est
beaucoup de temps j'aurais dû nommer
mois six mois et je vais réfléchir
tranquillement à ce projet voilà une
chandelle à six mois je donnerai un
projet ferme
est ce que j'ai fait j'ai travailler
calmement en ayant tous mes dossiers
sous les yeux chaque jour de mon atelier
pour regarder pour imprégner et puis
c'est dans le travail de l'atelier que
les choses sont mises à se mettre en
place tranquillement je suis capter
moment où je me suis dit cette
proposition c'est exactement ce que je
cherche pour la sienne c'est comme ça
que empêcher affiner le projet et que
les retravailler
ok merci la rochelle et c'est comme ça
qu'on avance
si je fais une maquette comme ça surtout
pour bien comprendre les aspects
techniques et les résistances des points
d'accrochage que la sculpture va subir
chaque ligne présente parce que hilton
ça va tenir que par un assemblage le
fait parce que 1100 kg il allait au 50e
alors il ya plusieurs angles de vue mais
un s'amusant aujourd'hui de regarder
comment la structure sera un grand que
le rapport de sheila
le public devrait avoir cette vision
sera par là
[Musique]
on
tu
moi ce que je viens de ce travail est
d'être un direct latam émotionnelle dans
le gall masterchef qui fait que l'on
fait des feux de la rampe à l'artisanat
parce que sinon ça devient très très
compliqué si on fait un petit projet
contre les multiples il y en aura un bon
ça fait partie d'une thématique du
travail d'écouté rationnelle du travail
il faut aussi que que que le ressenti
l'émotion
cela pour capri la pièce puis de
retrouver dans la pièce donc ça c'est
très important je réalise les libyens
pendant deux semaines et rationnelle et
après chat semble et c'est à ce moment
là que la magie opère
[Musique]
la sculpture fera six mètres devant
casino s'il est de potiers soudan des
poignets du 4 mai 50 dans le cadre d'une
période aide et trois mètres d'eau la
poutre de charpente métallique de 200 mm
on appelle du hb à qui sera entièrement
fermée voilà ce sera trois lignes
dassier qui mangeait comme ça
déjà il songea sortent de l'atelier donc
des fois je touche la coupe après on
verra
on aura le premier transport qui se pose
est donc sans trace pour ses mains de
nuit s'est passée paris donc il est
contré que ça énorme
les pompes dans le nord par exemple sont
plus bas que dans le sud
donc voilà il ya tout un tas de
contraintes ce qu'il faut ça que je
connaisse aussi quand on fait de la
sculpture
mais ça c'est de la part du transporteur
mais quand même vraiment avoir un petit
village en tête
voilà donc il ya des contraintes et
c'est contre villa bien sûr il faut
s'assurer que la pièce de la caisse
kendra une garantie du signal ensuite je
serai aussi que les normes de sécurité
ce que je pense qu'une pièce je prévois
ce que les sur les portants et il est
plus tendue je trouve encore une charge
de l'inter au cas où signé par exemple
ces personnes dessus pour fêter une
victoire de l'équipe de rugby de france
par exemple
voilà du coup il faut il faut tenir
compte de ça pour pas que la structure
soit à ce casse ou où sera mr ce parce
que ça c'est ma responsabilité
[Musique]
il
là ce sont des assistants comme s'agit
d'un qui porte un calcul et a prévenu
pas céder à la beauté parfois même si
ces grands monuments taille et bien ça
se joue au millimètre
parce que il n'ya par mm à la flore qui
on peut avoir des grosses différences
d'anglais et de s'évader coup je me
serve du ballon vers commenter et de
celui ci pour incliner les degrés voilà
c'est une patience de l'espace je suis
pas pressé
[Musique]
les chauves le parc parce qu'on attend
ça me permet de réfléchir à la salle de
la pièce au travail important parce que
même un rapport forte de faire une faire
une pièce comme ça casse et on se dit
qu'on travaille pour à l'espace l'espace
public pour les gens et il faut
simplement apprécier ces moments là
c'est que du plaisir
voilà et là j'y suis là alors je me sers
de tout cas je travaille je me sers de
dans des outils est sûre de mon corps
parce que je te lisent tous les maths
est bien sûr mais même mais aussi mes
jambes comme ça je me permets de le
caler
sortir
il fait passer nos pu s'appuyer sûr sûr
sûr le travail il faut que ça reste
quand même toujours du plaisir
il faut aussi répondre à d'autres
à l'époque à venir se présenter bon si
je coince l'exclure aujourd'hui
j'imagine qu'il me faut à peu près trois
mois de travail intense donc je préfère
dans un premier temps parce que l'hiver
arrive donc éclater n'est pas chauffé
dans vatan
dassier se réchauffer voilà et dès que
les beaux jours à l'europe pour entamer
la finition et les peintures ans donc
j'ai aussi mon travail d'atelier
fonction des conditions météo que lui a
remis à mm
[Musique]
tenez la gauche puis prenez la sortie
gris tennis en direction de valenciennes
sentent aujourd'hui on va faire le
premier repérage avec les services
techniques du sur le site et calais
normalement avec le masson
l'implantation de sculpture
mon avis qu'on aurait abouti tout à
l'heure mais là on va couper la
circulation pendant la nuit
on mettra le camion ici je vois ce faire
les frais quand même ici
la grue soit là où le côté ou de l'autre
peu importe et une fois que l'on prend
on prend les éléments les uns au centre
il a appris aux travailleurs à une fois
que l'on mettra la grue là le quand même
ça va partir et après on travaille
tranquillement sans le couper toute la
circulation
la démarche avec nicolas et original
c'est la première fois
finalement que la ville dans le domaine
de la traction géométriques passe une
commande
nicolas est d'une certaine façon un
successeur de bernard venet puisque
bernar venet qui a rencontré nicolas à
valenciennes ce dont je ne suis pas peu
fier voilà a été très positif sur le
travail de nicolas et en fait on avait
monté en 2011 à 32 communes de la région
un festival tous appelés rives dérive le
long du fleuve est ce trop dont des
villes traversées par le fleuve escaut
et nicolas exposé dans une commune à
côté de valenciennes et voir son travail
et moi m'a beaucoup séduit et vous voilà
ma cheminée ensemble je lui ai fait part
d'un des problèmes qui se posaient à moi
qui était de trouver une oeuvre pour un
rond point de la ville
une vraie oeuvre parce qu'on trouve
généralement sur beaucoup de rond-point
en france et il m'a dit je vais
réfléchir et s'était strictement sans
engagement et dont il a beaucoup
réfléchi à la question c'est un
rond-point complexe avec beaucoup de
voix qui arrivent dessus des voies
importantes des voies secondaires un
parc public le para publics de la ville
qui donnent sur ce rond point et pris un
jour de n'en rien d'aussi extrêmement
argumenté extrêmement travaillé et j'ai
présenté ce travail omer et et voilà
tout simplement tout le monde a été
convaincu je sais pas comment ça se
passe dans les villes dans les autres
villes mais à valenciennes c'est
totalement subjectif
parce que une oeuvre d'art c'est pas une
brique de soupe qui peut y avoir de
subjectivité dans la brique de soupe
aussi c'est un coup de coeur pour une
oeuvre mais pas seulement pour une autre
mais pour l'artiste c'est comme ça que
les opérations se sont fait toutes
celles qui sont faites à valenciennes
notamment en matière d'art contemporain
depuis 2007 avec un principe quand même
qu'ils aient l'abstraction géométrique
est peut-être la seule fourches caudines
avec l'humanité de l'artiste soit
imposée pour réussir à faire quelque
chose dans cette ville d'un peu de
malnutrition à faire donc je leur ai dis
pas qu'il faut pour bien accéder les
trucs donc de charge des camions mais
centrale au milieu sur le plot les
autres lignes en ensemble voilà c'est
pas c'est pas très compliqué voilà c'est
simple le feeling est bien passé donc
c'est ça va rouler alors oui
sa part d'un aspect historique puis
c'est la ville de jean baptiste carpeaux
et c'est la ville de france qui a eu le
plus grand nombre de grands prix de rome
puisque paris une cinquantaine une
majorité de sculpteur est donc l'idée
départ a été de dire il faut que tous
les sculpteurs valenciennois qui ont eu
un premier grand prix de rome où un
second peu importe soient présents dans
leur ville qu'on les aime qu'on les aime
pas alors l'idée est née de la ville
comme galerie d'exposition temporaire et
de proposer à des artistes de déposer
une oeuvre ou deux pendant deux ans
trois ans et puis un peu à la fois on a
eu des dépôts comme ça et puis on a eu
des rencontres
et puis il ya des gens qui sont plus
abordables auquel on a proposé de
d'acheter
on est dans une jardinerie musée des
beaux arts de valenciennes on à côté
d'une oeuvre de ce sculpteur anglais qui
s'appelle normal des world qui n'offrent
qui s'appelle à me tracasser
c'est un travail que j'aime beaucoup les
gens vont au musée mais il ya beaucoup
de gens qui vont pas au musée donc moi
je crois que pour la sculpture ya rien
de mieux que la rue que c'est mieux que
le musée et enfin il suffit de se
promener dans les rues de la ville pour
voir combien il commence à y avoir des
oeuvres un peu partout et on va
continuer à développer à la fois à
remplacer celles qui s'en vont et en
acquérir aussi parce que quand les
artistes sont jamais aussi importantes
quand ils sont vivants et que c'est bien
de participer au développement de leur
carrière et puis leur permettre de vivre
aussi simplement
eh bien on ne trouve la grande blanche
je souhaite après la ville et qu'il
fallait en septembre et puis on retire
aurait lorsque j'aurai à salé la
sculpture de sovar puisqu'arnaud à la
saint pry c'est pourquoi le public de
valenciennes on peut se familiarisent
avec avec la géométrie mon travail ça
devait être assez beau tout blanc la
neige
la sculpture blanche
laurent voulzy d'un petit nettoyage au
printemps mais c'est normal c'est parti
de blancs mais tout ça il semble que
l'acier brut
je suis content qu'elle soit là parce
qu'elle marche si bien univers que que
l'uci et détiennent et les volants
recouverte par les grands arbres qui l'a
nominée saran ferme l'espace et le cadre
avec le la structure du musée de nous va
bien après donc je suis assez content de
l'avoir fait sur le dépôt de la grande
blanche les les échos sont vraiment très
favorable à l'or il ya toujours des gens
qui n'aiment pas mais heureusement
l'habitude de dire que l'unanimité me
fait très peur la matière que les gens
s'y opposent trouve que ça ne va pas du
tout et argumente plutôt que ce soit là
l'indifférence non là j'ai vraiment le
sentiment que ça se passe bien alors
toujours des gens pour vous dire que
c'est toujours très bien
pas complètement aveugle vous dites mais
voilà je sens bien j'ai mes antennes
j'ai mon réseau qui me dit voilà les
gens globalement aime bien et qui a une
impatience à voir arriver la suivante
nicolas va améliorer la vie des
valenciennois pour l'éternité puisqu'il
va rester au moins la note d'éternité
puisque il est évident que achevée on va
avoir une éternité supérieure à celle de
nicolas et à la mienne je crois
[Musique]
oui
l'idée de cette installation comme ca
provisoire c'est de voir l'attitude que
la ligne centrale de la sculpture occupe
de l'espace du portail pour bien pour
calculer réellement les coupes
je devrai faire sur la psf finale à la
latitude que j'ai entre les côtés de
portail et la ligne sont de 20 cm donc
ça voudra dire que je vais assemblée la
sculpture a définitivement je devrais me
tenir à l'aplomb de cette digne de 20 cm
maximum
et là je pourrai sortir si je dépasse ça
soit obligé de casser le portage
je vais voir
il faut que la lui l'approché faire ici
soit égale à celle dao dans cette partie
nord est
dans cette attente il a hélas les jeux
ou pas position de la pièce et je suis
sûr que ça va tomber directement la voix
s'il manque des matières aussi faut
ajouter semble avoir lutté trois
centimètres et pèse 3,5
[Musique]
là
je suis en train de mettre en place la
taxe de permettra de maintenir les deux
lignes ensemble donc celle-ci être
complètement dans l'espace et il faut
que ça tienne je sais que cette partie
centrale la partie centrale c'est le
sait le corps de sculpture il ya toute
l'attention toute la rigidité sera ici
avec la troisième ligne et que je veux
je positionne à la semaine prochaine en
mettant le boulon d'augmenter
l'assemblage sont les boulons qui
prennent trois temps de chacun donc là
on est sur 12 zones de pression donc sa
réception
[Musique]
le travail se fait de manière empirique
mais moi je commence à voir un peu la
méprise le matériau je sais à peu près
que le grain de solides
vous travaillez sur les sur l'assemblage
mais n'empêche qu'il ya toujours cette
tension
mais lorsqu'on fait la pièce et il
manque la distance et cette distance
elle s'acquiert à prépare à maturité du
travail mais je sais que après cette
pièce là je pourrais aller beaucoup plus
loin encore dans le travail dans la
conception des pièces est ce que je peux
faire des choses des montagnes jusqu'à
maintenant je sais pas le cas voilà donc
nos rangs même plus grands je vais je
peux faire deux fois plus grand pour
donner une idée ça fait 12 mètres de
long et 6 mètres de haut ce qui fait en
gros la hauteur du volume de l'atelier
voilà et la poutrelle 400 par 400 dans
400 a fait ça et ça fait ça cette fois
déclarée comme ça quoi alors pour faire
plus grande part du gâteau c'est le cas
ça c'est d'aller plus loin dans la
recherche vaccinale est d'aller attendre
ces lignes dans l'espace est de mettre
en relation des sculptures avec
architecture
parce que là la structure par et grâce
mais dans l'espace ue même sa petite
mais elle est dimensionnée par rapport à
l'espace qui va l'accueillir certains
mais si je la mets par exemple à côté
d'un building à shanghai est les
véhicules notamment donné il faut aussi
avoir cette conscience que dans le
travail il faut pouvoir avoir la
possibilité de développer à long terme
et ça passe par le travail atelier ça va
se parer de la résolution de problèmes
techniques
c'est toujours un challenge c'est une
véritable histoire ce sont 23 sur le
travail sur les jours des soldes avant
l'atelier ou des mois seul
j'apprends quelque chose même si je suis
seul c'est repoussé ses limites et c'est
aussi un menu du rêve
cinq minutes du rêve dans la personne et
d'intercéder dans les personnes qui
regarderont la sculpture
comment ça tient qui voit là et cette
notion comme ça de liberté qui est
importante et c'est aussi de dire oh non
je vous laisse pas dicter par la matière
cheveux ma sculpture c'est une sculpture
de forme
c'est un propos formelle donc voilà je
dois amener la matière à mon attention
c'est pas le contraire
[Musique]
on a affaire à des limites mais on peut
déjouer limites voilà ça c'est important
c'est en regardant en regardant comment
la matière joue regardant comment ou
savry où ça travaille avec point où je
travaillais des endroits où ce travail
puisque l'autre donc ça c'est aussi en
observant avec avec le regard un regard
attentif on s'aperçoit que hâter un
droit et de la fabrique donc c'est vrai
c'est que ce travail travail en fonction
un citoyen d'ingénierie mais ça fait
partie de ces ultras du sculpteur à la
technicité
elle est important de connaître un art
et chic et peut-être certains artistes
contemporains l'oubli
lorsque je commence à faire les caisses
de bois je les faisais ici une statue
d'y travailler dehors ces défis que les
accueillir que les premières invitations
aux sons sont hélas eu lieu ensuite je
les ai développé par la suite un peu
plus une manière à plus affranchi de la
vague rose arnaud et voilà donc c'est
ici que c'est à cause est parti je
n'utilise pour mais voilà tout ce qui ma
gestion de mon travail
le dessin est depuis peu la peinture qui
la peinture et venir le temps que la
scolarisation des cultures dans l'ancien
c'était un besoin pour garder une
fraîcheur intellectuelle dans la dureté
du travail de l'atelier 2 nuls en
atelier lorsque j'ai commencé à jouer au
jeu j'avais un plan sur cette table avec
des photos du site et après j'ai fait un
chef une dossier dans l'idée c'est de se
dire mais voilà comment comment on
appréhende ce lieu comment on y arrive
comment le vit comment on en ressort
dans du coup ce sont des choses qui sont
axées que sur des mouvements circulaires
du temps de sa forme mais à la fois
c'est presque un automne
l'idée c'était que dans la sculpture on
est aussi ce mouvement comme ça quand
j'ai réussi à donner car justement
l'inclinaison des lignes dans l'espace
et de créer manière à ce que le sport
automobile saoulé de coups le piéton
lorsqu'il fait le tour de la place il
estime que ça tourne entre l'ordinateur
et le kimono l'impasse a soudé parce que
je travaille sur un projet et bien je me
sers beaucoup de la photo je me sers de
traduction de l'atelier ensuite je fais
images de synthèse de manière à ce que
des
les commanditaires élus au goût
particulier il a une vision très précise
du rendu final c'est important parce que
même pour moi ça me permet d'ajuster la
démesure de la pièce donc on va d'un
grand rectangle blanc sur lequel la
sculpture est posée lorsque je suis de
l'atelier justin même que je suis noir
du thon parce que même dans leur canton
pourrait beaucoup d'artistes qui font un
type qui en main plutôt une démarche où
un ou des oeuvres sont trop un emprunt
de du mono comptent un point dans
laquelle on est soit trop changer de
technologie ou moi j'essaye d'être en
dehors de tout ça parce que la distance
avec le recul nous sommes nécessaires
pour à comprendre le monde alternée
[Applaudissements]
à
c'est sec mois fait deux mois de travail
avec des phases très différentes par
moments des fins de mobutu de françois
nouveau tome et d'inquiétude par rapport
à la version des projets de sorties de
combats de durée dans le temps de
pouvoir avoir toujours la fraîcheur
intellectuelle du travail artistique
dans la proximité du travail est dans la
difficulté physique du travail
sculpture représente passage certains de
nos sens où elle a une autre conception
de l'espace que des écuyers ses
précédentes tempêtes pour maintenir la
masse de la sculpture puisque certaines
lignes aujourd'hui je peux dire plus
d'une tonne quasiment une tournée de
miliana polling et donc ces faillites et
ce défi technique est aussi important
aujourd'hui et qui me laisse présager
demain à aller encore plus loin dans
l'idée de l'attention des lignes et de
la conception de la sculpture alors
c'est certain passage tout passage
demande après avoir une autre une autre
étape
je vais là fixé encore plus haute
l'ambitieuse juste pour le plaisir de
pouvoir aller soit plus loin dans la
recherche dans le jeu dans la prise de
risque qui est pour moi quelque chose
d'important si on avance un ami
laisse le temps au temps voilà je sais
ce que je fais confiance au temps c'est
une chance de revenir c'est bien sûr une
passe pas grave
en tout cas ce qu important c'est que
chaque jour que je suis là je prenne du
plaisir à faire ce que je fais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
vous souhaitez nous arriver
[Musique]
je vous avez terriblement
c'est pas la plus grande puisque la plus
grande à ce jour ce serait augmentée
l'humeur le fait sept mètres dos aussi
aller à des les plus complexes des
grandes et des plus complexes parce que
montélimar qui était ouverte
si les banques fermées donc on entend
tout le poids
la conception spatial n'est pas la même
donc c'est la plus complexe au travail a
été important puisqu'il était parce
qu'il m'a permis de se demander d'ouvrir
à sculptures dans les pièces à
l'intérieur elles sont moins grandes
donc du coup
les soudures d électro se suffisait pour
que les lichens lorsqu on a beaucoup
plus de portée on sait que l'acier sexy
bhl ça se plie donc il faut venir le
renforcer les endroits précis de manière
à ce qu'ils se cassent pas par la suite
[Musique]
côté droit
je suis content de cette pièce me laisse
présager une ouverture pu rentrer dans
mon travail et des prises de risque plus
importante
les limites il n'y a pas de limites des
limites si elle consomme donc je ne
donne pas de limite 14 par la
croix-rouge leiser après on monte la
vase y apprendre à gauche
[Musique]
c'est pas des chevrons pas du tout parce
que c'est même une certaine certain
plaisir d'aller la partager avec le
public
je suis en attente de ce moment assez
agréable qui vont combler les segments
de solitude de l'atelier
et puis je suis votre projet d'entente
et une tarte seule chose c'est
recommencer une autre pièce pour
avancer plus loin dans la prise de
risque de dispositifs des lignes d'un
responsable
il faut penser que la sculpture a fait
pour aussi précis donc il ya une départ
à une conception qui est circulaire
c'est la place des circulaires donc on a
une vision que ça pour une fois qu'il ya
une mouvement parce qu'on découvre la
structure de woking s commission a
retenu soir en faisant le tour de la
pièce
[Musique]
créer la pièce en fonction du lieu du
snop qu'elle soit juste dans le rapport
spatiale avec avec l'espace
je veux pas que la paix soit trop grande
faut pas imposer les choses moi je ne
veux pas la prendre comme ça que ça mais
je l'apprécié de faire la chose de
gratuit c'est juste possible
l'offre est brassée le sol dur me permet
de caler avec l'autre élément avec
l'abandon sans repères donc de ce fait
pas tout
merci
vrai quand il faut et quand m 2 semblant
on passe de chaque côté on lève
la soirée peu après la pause
à mulhouse
on encore
on sait que sa mère
j'ai vu le lieu j'aurai la réponse de la
réponse quand est ce que ce sera posée
je verrai si j'ai bien capté l'espace
ces dispositifs de son positionnement
d'un espace du rond point de la place et
juste rapport aux visions que je vais me
promener et de la sculpture
voilà tout ça ça a été imaginé à partir
d'un plan à partir d'imagés cents
j'espère que mon ipod mais le ressenti
du lieu sera juste et voilà je ferais si
je restais un peu c'est le peut si elle
est juste niveau sa dimension d'être
sera t-elle un peu petite soit elle
passe à quelle dimension c'est pas une
prochaine fois on sait bien faire
peut-être différemment mais je pense que
je pense tous radium
c'est bon
c'est bon allez c'est un boulot énorme
et d'autre l'autre partie et après on
nous a juste bien par rapport au centre
or aurait juste comme il faut les
patines de béton et après c'est fini
c'est fini
commandée dans le timing on attend
il me semble
[Musique]
vainqueur
l'important c'est la relation qui peut y
avoir entre chaque ligne
l'une de l'autre et leur discours leur
disposition de la direction qu'elle soit
à la fois proche patron pas trop éloigné
parce que c'est le centre wallonie la
sculpture se creuse il n'y a pas de
cohérence et donc c'est sa c6 trouver ce
juste milieu
c'est les lignes se marie elle ce qui
fait le lien entre elles sur des points
et là ce sont des plus fragiles
elle repasse juste sur des anglais sert
de fragilité mon idée c'est que
finalement pour que les choses contre
des êtres humains existent et fera vivre
normalement ouvrir ce que je sais pas si
noblement pas mais les pouvoirs avant
une en équilibre à soi c'est cette
distance comme et par rapport les uns
aux autres de manière à ce que les
choses soient justes voilà donc je
m'intéresse moi je regarde juste qui le
monde essaye de faire avec des mes
ressentis avec mon histoire d'essayer de
mettre en place ses idées dans une
proposition formelle qui au demeurant
est devenu par rapport à une suite
logique du travail alors là tous les
jours les concepts sont mis en place et
une certaine idée de l'âge metrics mis
en place voilà donc cesser de résultats
d'observations simples au quotidien dans
le temps qui font que les choses
prennent une valeur d'existence
d'épaisseur et se développe après
je
ouais dessus et dessous
[Musique]
soit tu peux les réseaux les c'est
parfait mais je paye ça marche bien et
j'aime leur est pour le coup nous avions
encore parler de deux heures va pas
s'excuser c'est les mêmes sources mais
je la conçois la grâce au disque ne sera
plus vite je vais le faire je le ferai
le père qui ferait la finition patron de
roche pour l'équipe son journal
on enlève un élève on enlève des bottes
deux heures de boulot pour essayer de
finir les platines la forme d'un paquet
là-dessus
voilà donc c'est après ça c'est ignorer
de metz il faut se réduit
merci beaucoup ward chasseurs voix
monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup
voile sous revue
[Applaudissements]
mais bon là voilà alors il est écrit
achevé 11 et donc il expliquera ensuite
qui est cet âge les 11 voilà voilà
h c'est le temps du matériau h2ad des
salles de l'ancienne en année grand
qu'un set c'est vraiment sympa on va
selon lui le pakistan voilà on a compris
le pourquoi
voilà
[Musique]
à bien
le plus possible
vol et conçue en fonction de l'espace
oui quand même
parce qu'on peut pas
à
pour une fois
les sentiers puis les sources comme
étant
oui
coupe du monde
20 sculptures
il faut que ça tire c'est le propre de
la sculpture à il faut que ça tienne
physiquement et plastiquement donc il ya
double un jeu comme ça je conçois et ça
c'est très important de pouvoir mono et
bien lier ces deux de manière s'il ne se
soient pas immédiatement perceptibles
mais que la lancement des lignes efface
cette relation qu'on peut avoir avec
avec la pièce avec ceux ci
cette émotion comme possible d'avoir
avec l'union parce qu'on sait pas trop
comment les fait que le tien c'est là la
magie de la sculpture ça va j'essaie
d'avoir une forme comme ça dans l'espace
[Musique]
pour
le
[Musique]
nous
mais
[Musique]